[Music]
when I work I really try to reproduce
smell scenarios for different purposes
speed creepy the neighborhood in the
city I've some coastal smell all over
the world could we on behalf of a small
molecule find out something about
history but we otherwise would know this
is sisal Tallis she has many things an
artist a scientist but more importantly
a smell expert she however prefers
another title and call myself a
professional in-betweener which means
what exactly
there's a whole world to smell and the
whole world to educate how to flow so
you cannot just limit yourself to one
discipline right the point is she has
dedicated her life to the sense of smell
what it means how it can be used to
better understand the world and each
other pretty early in my life I started
ask questions why are we only
understanding the world on behalf of how
the world look like what if we started
using other senses more appropriate for
the same purpose of my web and starting
to discover the same world I've been
looking at for several years using the
nose for the purpose so how exactly did
you go about recording and then
reproducing these smells I will walk
around identify smells with my own nose
I have a small devices that enable me to
Kollek the smell molecules emitting from
the source with the results I go to my
lab and then the data I get back is them
the starting point of reproduction of
the actions now I have a lab consisting
of up to 4,000 chemical compounds and
with those ingredients is with those
compounds
I literally reproduce invisible reality
that surround you full-time all the time
name a city a neighborhood within a
neighborhood a historical building or
even in era in time and most likely
sizzle has reproduced that smell along
with thousands of other scents here in
her lab with the hoax of using the
findings for a bigger purpose the
purpose can be total education
levitation to memorize the list and less
is more interesting if you really start
understand us now
and see how you can use that information
for a purpose beyond miss mallison
[Music]